you also write the problem with
Communism is that eventually you run out
of possible Escape boat Escape boats
skip boats you run out of boats you do
run out of boats who's going to carry
them
uh eventually you run out of possible
skate because it's uh it's it's my
second language this English thing
I'm a failed podcaster I'm a failure uh
eventually you run out of possible
Escape goats for failure at which point
acknowledging or even noticing that
something was wrong itself becomes a
form of treason yeah so I saw that in
North Korea right wherever you went in
North Korea something was wrong so if
you have four buttons for the elevator
one would be mismatched every wall had a
crack every floor had a stain uh the
bathroom would be rusted through when
you want to flush the urinal but if you
are someone who points this out you're a
troublemaker and you're oh you're crazy
oh you're saying something's wrong
you're criticizing the operation you
create you're first of all you're you're
threatening the person who's in charge
because now they're incompetent and now
that's a big red flag for them but
second if you're just going around
saying this is wrong this is wrong this
is wrong even if it's objectively true
your troublemaker and your
counter-revolutionary so at a certain
point everyone just has to put on
blinders and pretend that everything is
fine one example I use in the book an
extreme example was there was a
photography professor and he pointed out
to his class and he was an older man
that before the Revolution the quality
of photographic paper was better and he
was I think executed uh for this heresy
so yeah you have to pretend there was I
just I'm reading book right now about
the Chinese Cultural Revolution and
there was an academic I I forget his
name Yushi I think and he points out
that in these countries
not only do you not have freedom of
speech you don't have freedom of Silence
you can't just sit there quietly you
have to say how great things are and how
much you're enjoying and how wonderful
they are instead of just keeping quiet
because if you keep quiet that's
suspicious
yeah those um
they're always singing those songs about
how happy they are and how great
everything is and if everyone else is
singing who are you to sing not sing
yeah those uh pictures especially when
uh you know when it's Stalin giving
speeches and everyone is applauding any
any dictator and you do you you don't
want to be the the first person that
stops applauding Stalin had to have a
button it's my understanding at a
certain point to tell people to stop
applauding because they're like you said
if you're the first one to stop clapping
people are going to notice and why'd you
stop clapping you don't like Stalin
but just imagine being one of those
people collaping but that's the thing
they they always had a sword over their
head and they have but they all had a
lot of blood in their hands too it's
it's it's it's a it's a very very
precarious life
but there's also I mean 1984 does a good
job of this
um what is that like two minutes of hate
or something like this you like lose
yourself in the in the in the in the
hysteria of it in the history so there's
some level of which
at first it's uh you're sacrificing your
basic individualistic ability to think
but then you get lost in this kind of
wave of emotion and you give in to it
you allow yourself it's like a mix of
fear and then anger and then you direct
that anger towards like snowball or
Trotsky or whoever the and like what is
that and you're also losing yourself in
the crowd yeah you lose you're like it's
not just I'm angry everyone I know we're
all Angry together so you really are
becoming a part of something bigger than
yourself and having this kind of
communal very Primal emotional
experience
it's like the opposite of thanks of
Christmas right Christmas we're all
together everyone's sharing their Joy
everyone's sharing their love this is
the opposite literally the opposite like
everyone's together sharing their hate
and anger and rage but you're all kind
of having a mind meld
but I wonder what it's like to be an
independent thinker in those in those
moments like allow yourself to think
well we we know because there were a lot
of them and they were all punished
enormously so they can be noticed you
can notice them oh yeah you even noticed
it in America America is a free country
but when people start asking too many
questions it's like where are you going
with this you know like if you're in an
office even in a corporate setting uh
you're you're a troublemaker you're just
you know you're making problems for
everyone why can't you be normal why
can't you be just like everybody else so
people do not like having to be made to
think and they certainly despise having
to be made to justify themselves
um because that's a threat to their
status into their power and this applies
in totalitarianism applies to you know
Dunder Mifflin